estamos atravessando um momento muito
delicado em nosso planeta
é como se estivéssemos pisando em
casquinhas de ovos
tendo que tomar todo cuidado toda
atenção para não quebrá las porque a
quebra representa conseqüências
negativas irreparáveis
além de todos os sintomas que são comuns
a todos
é como os efeitos da mudança climática
como a crescente violência especialmente
no que tange à intolerância às
diferenças
a crise econômica
e todas as demais manifestações cada
lugar em seu desafio particular
por exemplo aqui no brasil estamos
vivendo essa epidemia de corrupção
mas é importante observar
que crises sempre existiram e talvez
continuarão a existir
se nós não tratarmos da causa desses
distúrbios
todas essas crises começam dentro de nós
mesmos
é a crise está dentro de nós
o externo é um reflexo daquilo que está
se passando dentro de nós mesmos e que
está se passando inclusive dentro de
você e não acredita que tenha
absolutamente nada a ver com essas
crises estão acontecendo lá fora
é muito óbvio a necessidade de uma
reforma de tudo aquilo que está
acontecendo lá fora
por exemplo aqui no brasil
precisamos de uma reforma política e uma
reforma fiscal
uma reforma no sistema econômico
sabemos o quanto é urgente hoje
uma reforma no sistema capitalista
mundial
precisamos encontrar soluções sim para a
equação da sustentabilidade
mas nós precisamos de uma reforma
interior
nós precisamos de uma reforma de valores
sem essa reforma nós vamos continuar
eternamente tratando de efeitos
tratando de sintomas
os sintomas se modificam ao longo do
tempo
amanhã os problemas serão outros
mas continuarão a existir
podemos observar
através do principal instrumento de
aferição que temos
como está o nosso estado interior
e através das relações humanas
a relação humana quanto mais íntima
maior tem o poder de a ferir de mostrar
como nos encontramos
internamente
como você tem se relacionado
você tem sido capaz de criar relações
construtivas e positivas amorosas
você tem criado a monia
na sua família
em todos os lugares aonde você passa
porque a vida é relacionamentos
estamos conta constantemente nos
relacionando com tudo com todos
eu tenho dito que se a vida é uma escola
relacionamentos é a sua universidade
e como toda a universidade temos provas
e temos inclusive uma prova final ea
prova final na universidade dos
relacionamentos é conseguir deixar o
outro livre inclusive para nos amar
se ele não quiser ou se ele não puder
esse é o nosso grande desafio
eu tenho trazido o conceito do novo
casamento
o novo casamento
como
tendo como base o amor ea liberdade
e isso por sua vez é a base para uma
nova consciência por uma nova sociedade
o casamento é a célula da família
e à família é a célula da sociedade
se fomos capazes de criar harmonia no
casamento nós criaremos também a
harmonia na família e criaremos harmonia
na sociedade
o novo casamento implica numa reforma de
valores
ele implica em transparência
ele implica em honestidade
e segredos de maneira alguma
significa em assumir responsabilidade
pelas turbulências que surgem na relação
ou seja uma relação onde existe amor
porém amor consciente amor maduro que é
o amor desinteressado
esse novo casamento
ele evoca uma mudança interior
nós estamos falando de uma mudança de
cultura
numa reforma de valores
falando de honestidade
estou falando de alta responsabilidade
estou falando de gentileza
esses são três
quero que seja um urgentes neste momento
em que nós estamos atravessando
esses valores são manifestações do
próprio amor
por quê
as crises ou sintomas que percebemos são
oriundos do desamor
todas as dificuldades que vemos na cim
do desamor
se existe um remédio para esse mundo
o remédio é o amor porém amor consciente
que é o amor desinteressado
mas para que esse amor se manifeste e
possa se expressar através dos nossos
dons dos nossos talentos
nós precisaremos acordar e seus valores
o valor de volta o outro
mas precisamos começar de alguma maneira
e é por isso que eu tenho sugerido que
comecemos através daqueles
a questão mais esquecidos
o primeiro valor que eu considero que
esteja mais esquecido é o valor da
honestidade
honestidade evoca verdade evoca
integridade
primeiramente honestidade em relação a
nós mesmos
é a coragem de admitir as nossas
insatisfações
a coragem de admitir
aquilo que não está
de acordo com os nossos desejos mais
profundos
é coragem de admitir as nossas
imperfeições
é a coragem de admitir as nossas
limitações
esse é o primeiro passo para que
possamos superar essas limitações
só quando reconhecemos identificamos
aquilo que não está adequado que não
está funcionando bem dentro de nós é que
podemos transformar em superar e depois
a honestidade em relação ao mundo à
nossa volta
a publicidade está intimamente
relacionada com espontaneidade
a relacionado com a inocência
através da honestidade começamos a
resgatar o nosso lugar no mundo
outro valor alto responsabilidade
se observarmos veremos que o mundo se
tornou uma vítima das influências
exteriores
ao reis uma das maiores distrações no
ser humano seja o jogo de acusações
o ser humano se distrai acreditando que
o outro é o responsável pela sua
infelicidade
ele acredita que o outro responsável
pela incapacidade de amar pela
incapacidade dele de manifestar o poder
que lhe é inerente
que outro responsável pela incapacidade
de manifestar a grandeza dele
então alta responsabilidade implica em
compreender que estamos aonde nos
colocamos
eu estou aonde eu me coloco você está e
aonde você se coloca você está aonde
você se coloca
por mais que existam sim em influências
exteriores também
mas partimos do
sílvio que se você ficou perturbado
ao invés de olhar para a montanha de
defeitos do outro você deve olhar o
grande defeito em você
e trata de transformar esse grande
defeito em você
e terceiro a gentileza resgatar o
respeito pelo outro na forma como nos
comunicamos uma comunicação não violenta
uma comunicação amorosa querer para o
outro somente aquilo que você quer para
você mesmo
esses valores
são como sementes
ao serem plantadas germinaram
floresceram
e darão frutos
para isso se faz necessário
primeiramente compreender a necessidade
dessa reforma interior
se faz necessário compreender que além
das reformas externas
precisamos nos submeter a essa reforma
interna
é possível é possível
eles é possível nos relacionarmos de uma
forma harmoniosa
é possível empreender de uma forma
absolutamente saudável
respeitando a sustentabilidade
é possível fazer o dinheiro circular de
uma forma positiva trazendo prosperidade
para todos
mas pra isso
o empreendedorismo precisa ter base no
autoconhecimento
essa é a mensagem central
eu quero trazer hoje
de que o autoconhecimento precisa se
tornar política pública
ele precisa acontecer em larga escala
ele precisa se manifestar em todos os
segmentos da nossa sociedade
tudo aquilo que você vier fazer no mundo
precisa nascer
a intenção sincera de querer ver o outro
feliz
precisa ter como base os princípios de
uma cultura de paz e de prosperidade
nesse momento precisamos pensar
globalmente
e precisamos unir os nossos esforços
unir os nossos dons e talentos
para acordar a consciência amorosa
para nos tornarmos canais
esse amor maduro
para darmos passagem uma nova
consciência
isso é possível isso está acontecendo
esse encontro é um exemplo disso
é verdadeiramente maravilhoso que está
acontecendo aqui
é como se estivéssemos plantando
sementes
mas estou aqui hoje convidando a todos
vocês estão me ouvindo
para se tornarem jardineiros
para que possamos cantar mais e mais
sementes e todos os lugares em todos os
setores
nós precisamos renovar o sistema
educacional
precisamos iluminar o sistema de saúde
nós precisamos repensar o sistema
prisional
precisamos
iluminar a gestão pública
cada país tem seus desafios
cada cidade tem seus desafios cada
família tem seus desafios
cada casal tem seus desafios
mas se formos procurar um denominador
comum
nós vamos encontrar que todos os
desafios têm base na ausência de valores
valores como esses que eu estou
finalizando
então eu amazônico receba minhas bênçãos
receba meu amor
possamos realmente crescer crescer cada
vez mais
no amor e na consciência